[Music]
yourself
[Music]
louder with Crowder is brought to you in
part
by.com
head over to the shop support the fight
and buy some cool threads it's the tits
pajamas
.com
[Music]
[Applause]
it's June which marks louder with
Crowder's sixth annual cultural
appropriation month where we take you
across the globe to learn and appreciate
all the diverse cultures this planet has
to offer because to appropriate is to
appreciate
this week allow us to get you acquainted
with the land that brought us philosophy
lesbianism and National bankruptcy
Greece
[Music]
please
that's a good thing to be known for and
nothing else in the modern world no I'm
kidding Greece has done a lot just not
much since the abacus
well it was a good invention uh it is
cultural appropriation month so uh
before we get to a recap of Biden and
Putin which is important uh and we're
also going to be talking about the new
domestic terrorism I don't know what you
call it watch policy this is from
whitehouse.gov and it should terrify you
uh it's time for uh some obviously some
some grease facts oh yeah yeah and of
course many of us uh we're going to have
a costume contest for you so you're
always in your costume and we'll read
the winner in one Club so many of us
know that ancient Greece was made up of
sovereign city states like Sparta and
Athens but Scholars actually estimate
that there were about 1500 individual
city-states that's a lot that is a lot
yeah uh the Greeks performed the first
nude scene in the history of European
Cinema in the film Daphne uh daphnis and
Chloe ah and uh Mamma Mia Menino was
filmed in Greece but unfortunately no
one was killed during the making of that
film so that was a tough one we have uh
Gerald egg is here
um hey I don't know did he get the
message no no he never does I don't know
guys grease stop moving stop moving
Danny Zuko I don't I by the way this is
not a joke I don't know how I feel about
the fact that the the one person has to
be a statue I'll show is the intern with
actual Tourette's it's true ah I don't
know what part of him's gonna twitch the
most oh no quarterback Eric how are you
what's going on
hey he added some twang to it and
follow him on the top
I don't even know what that means it
sounded is that is what you light on
fire before sangupa it's like uh Alaska
yeah it's like the original grilled
cheese only more poor yeah I don't know
how you make a grilled cheese sandwich
more poor no even Americans they added a
show right in water they did water for
this weekend 9 p.m show they added for
Saturday come on out okay all right
that's gonna be a lot of yeah they had
to add a show because it's full and I
only recommend it Dave is Dave is quite
the character he's funny man cut up and
stand up and you can follow us by the
way on Instagram Tick Tock even though
it's destroying Society I figured I'll
fight the chat comms where they'd be oh
geez and uh the best thing you can do
just it's a live show Monday through
Thursday at 10 A.M Eastern before we
move on to Biden Putin which was
incredibly embarrassing we were
streaming it live yesterday in real time
not good and what's interesting is as we
were streaming it live I was saying oh
Putin is flexing right now yeah he's
insulting the United States he's
implying that the United States are the
real terrorist actors he's throwing this
back in by his face and then all of the
coverage was huge Victory bye
of course of course it was it's the same
thing with election night just that's
the value of why we do this live and for
people who don't you know YouTube values
live yeah streaming right now they're
really trying to move into that space
anytime you go to the live page we're
usually number one and three and like
several yeah yeah and that's why they're
like what can we do they change the live
page to just remove us oh my gosh which
is fine well no but you're not
flattering election night was a perfect
example we covered the votes coming in
where we were going well it looks like
Donald Trump's going to win the Michigan
like 163 what that just happened right
now they announced it on many liberal
news sources yeah yeah no Michigan all
these things and so we experienced it
live that's why it wasn't taken down
because it wasn't considered considered
a conspiracy theory where we were all
going
that seems a little Shifty yeah well and
what you see live with us is US
commenting on it like the headline when
it came up like Biden is complimented by
Putin on his morals it was like wait
what he tell us more about your summer
yeah exactly like you guys think that's
the win because Vladimir Putin said well
he's a moral man I can work with this
man tell me more what
hey before we get to that though it's
time to react to this uh this is on Tick
Tock it's pride month this is a uh
that's been making rounds on The Tick
Tock where I am and I hate myself for it
it's a gay uh song encouraging you to
also be gay I am gay
you didn't have to tell us
so it's a choice
gosh if I were a woman I would be so
offended now oh my it's like this is all
the Splendor that is Womanhood clown
makeup I'm offended by how nice this
house is
chandelier complete lack of talent yeah
is that your mom and dad what rhymes
with that if you're not gay that is too
bad hold on a second I know I'm saying
we're accepting applications right at
what point does an immutable
characteristic become a choice is he
saying you can change they also is he
really immutable or can we mute him what
a little a little but why is he dressed
like it's the 17th century mixed with
clowning yeah well well well that's a
black guy too no wait no no no
Mary J Blige is a bookcase that turns
into a queen yes hashtag Oscar's too
white like it's 17 for
eign
[Laughter]
it was the clowns party um hey by the
way I want to ask this is a question for
everyone out there have you seen the
reporting on Biden and Putin and I want
to be clear no one here is rooting for
Putin I wish that he respected our
president right I just think that he
clearly doesn't and we'll get to all the
clips uh that are relevant from
yesterday at least what I think we have
all the sources available at lotto.com
comment below uh God we're all gonna die
I wish the Russian people had the balls
to get rid of him I really do your
statue's itching itself
is that a normal itch or is that a
Tourette's I think it was a Tourette's
itch that was it that was a test don't
talk oh oh gosh
he failed the first test I didn't say
Tourette says
he's wearing a lot of makeup from all
the black guys Stephen gave him in
rehearsals
I'll show
we'll try the fish okay so over the
weekend uh I don't know if you know this
about the Island of Lesbos but for
Afghan youth Utes were given the maximum
sentence 10 years in jail yeah for um
Burning Down The Moria or is it Moria
it's more Memoria uh migrant camp on the
Island of Lesbos actually and this
happened uh this happened in September
2020 and then they were just sentenced I
believe over the weekend here's a clip
of the fire that they set Island of
Lesbos
[Music]
[Applause]
they're all going to the tick-tocker
premiere ah oh it's the fire Festival
all right that's enough I think is that
the Subaru Factory yes hopefully
but we'll take out the transportation
hubs yes it's Subaru cares
softball maker
so a lot of people don't realize the
word lesbian while we're doing cultural
appropriation month Greece was actually
it comes from the island of lesbo yes
which was the birth birthplace of the
Greek poet sappho ah and it was sort of
uh it was the first discovered
uh lesbian by um Galapagos ah
and uh actually this is something a lot
of people don't know this actually
Lesbos that's why it's called that
beautiful obviously Mediterranean island
oh yeah and uh because it's cultural
probation month and we need to blow some
budget this quarter because in the tax
policy we actually have some uh Lesbos
residents in their natural habitat
foreign
told you to get a Whole 30 pack
by the way I don't know the one on the
right just took Heidi klum's job oh man
are we talking about that Victoria's
Secret is no longer good no apparently
yeah they're getting rid of the angels
and replacing them with lesbians ah
we'll talk about that in a little bit
why everything has to be ruined but uh
flannel underwear yeah can't wait
so sexy yes yeah Fredericks of Hollywood
is just a model named Frederick with
preferred Z pronouns just selling Doc
Martens
what's uh what's what's the season this
year it's Crocs I think I think you
should go with some khaki frocks it's
functional shut up so
yesterday uh Biden Putin they held
separate press conferences that's always
a good sign yeah yeah after the meeting
uh now note of course Trump and Putin
held a duel conference I want to go back
to uh 2018 and of course in case you've
forgotten CNN lost their minds this is
then uh you have been watching perhaps
one of the most disgraceful performances
by an American president what at a
summit leader uh you are fake I've ever
seen uh an extraordinary uh press
conference
go back to your repurposed Firehouse you
East Village you'll ruin New Year's Eve
I want it to be 20. the only reason he
signed that contract was because he
thought he got to see Dick Clark's balls
he showed up man not again oh Gene my
good news we got Kathy Griffin and he's
like oh God uh even him
it's got worse okay so this is a little
bit long but I want you guys to see this
and again we have the the sources
available at lottery.com so you can
watch the entirety of these press
conferences Putin took substantially
longer yeah uh although Biden took
substantially longer to make his way to
the podium
hours hours yeah uh but mainly Vladimir
Putin if people are talking about how we
need to have we need to have a
commander-in-chief who is tough on uh
tough on Russia tough on Putin look he
spent most of his press conference we
were there live crapping on the United
States and very clearly taking shots at
Biden which the leftist media took his
compliments look when he says he's an
experienced Statesman when Putin says
that about former Vice President Joe
Biden he's calling him a swamp creature
because this is what you have to have
historical context he complimented
Donald Trump Remember by saying he's a
businessman and he approaches it to like
from a business sense so this is good
this is refreshing like what do you
think about Biden he is experienced as a
matter of fact all he ever has done is
DC so
no that's great that's great yeah oh I
mean oh it's impressive yes I've killed
people but your president is a scumbag
yes that's fine I've killed people
Anderson who could fit you in their back
pocket yes
so uh here is a montage uh just so you
can see the highlights from Vladimir
Putin dumping on the U.S and showing his
respect for former Vice President Biden
okay everything that happened and
happens in our countries one way or
another
um
is the responsibility of the leaders
themselves
look at the streets of America every
single day there are shootings and
killings and on human rights listen to
me he's a jerk but he's not wrong
it's still working
you didn't answer my question sir if all
of your political opponents are dead in
prison poison doesn't that send a
message that you do not want a fair
political fight people
right it and went into the Congress in
the U.S with political demands and many
people were
decorated as criminals and they are
threatened with imprisonment from 20 to
25 years we sympathize with what was
happening in the States but we do not
wish that to happen in Russia tell us
what did you see when you looked at him
in the eyes as far as uh looking in eyes
and finding uh Souls a concerned well uh
I actually don't remember that he family
he has no soul yeah
[Music]
wow dude
saying that they found this soul in the
former Vice President Joe Biden
but I'm really not saying uh that I did
[Laughter]
I absolutely took it it was
it was looking into eye of [ __ ]
Michael shark yes like you know shark
who don't know not to jump out of the
water and land in boats so you eat
it looked into the eyes of many people
I've killed and in their last moments
they look very desperate but not as
desperate
the man who before I burn alive in
Karbonn yes have more courage than
former Vice President Joe Biden yes I
have put uh how you say a tire around
the neck and cover it in gasoline to
people who look uh better at life than
him yes and I only at least I only admit
because I did not fear any
accountability no right now
a silly week old man yes
uh by the way another recent example
I've talked about this yesterday Donald
Trump was people can say overly
complimentary of Putin I think it's a
fair uh criticism but he was tough on
Russia and here's the issue there's a
long track record with former Vice
President Joe Biden under the Obama
Administration who some would argue is
still pulling the strings in a lot of
ways if not Kamal Harris
um were they claimed they would be tough
on Russia and then they weren't and then
there's there are plenty of examples
where they claim they were going to be
tough on Russia and then said hey uh the
80s called they want their uh they want
their Cold War policy back to Mitt
Romney so it was very inconsistent with
Donald Trump you do you do have to
acknowledge that he was consistently
unpredictable look someone who's
unpredictable keeps you on your toes you
know that's what happened yeah so here's
the juxtaposition right you have
somebody saying Assad there's a red line
and if you cross it it's a red line he
goes well okay I'll cross it crosses it
and then nothing happens and then you
have a guy like Donald Trump
understanding that negotiation sometimes
means you can't just say whatever you
want but then you can be tough in your
policy well a perfect example of this
tangibly when we're talking something
that can be Quantified because we're
talking about policy what do you think
Putin thinks when President he just said
Joe Biden former Vice President Joe
Biden gotta make sure I get that right
he just said you know we're saying that
America's back okay well you shut down
the Keystone Pipeline here but then you
uh you waved sanctions against the
Russia's Nordstrom too yeah their own
pipeline Germany yeah exactly by the way
I think we should keep our eyes on both
of them I agree
I think the pipeline was a great idea
the gas prices going down right now in
the realm of human history 70 years
isn't all that long Germany
you're still unnoticed and look they did
it twice yeah it's not like they don't
have a history of sequels no they're
gonna keep your enemies closer kind of
idea
yeah this is true This Is My Philosophy
that's why I use buy them as a footstool
shut up oh though man the Ottomans can't
[ __ ] yeah I haven't shine my shoes but I
hate this he's not good at nothing and
these speed glands no longer work
she speeds dust like Komodo dragon hey
it's time for uh with all this context
this weekend wait if you have a problem
figuring out whether you're for me or
Trump and you ain't black okay so a few
things that Biden got wrong here when he
was talking at his press conference uh
Outdoors by the way yes
I also love how he put on his sunglasses
like three times to leave and then came
back
to Miami like
I Won't Get Fooled Again huh I got four
questions okay the Guess Who it's the
who oh Joe what the hell's the
difference it's a huge difference
there's two different things so Biden
began by saying out loud that he was
given a list of reporters to call on he
said this here you go okay I'll take
your questions and as usual folks they
gave me a list of the people as usual so
uh Jonathan Associated Press
okay wow so comparing this again
that's all he does a position of
strength now here's the issue you would
have with Donald Trump if Donald Trump
had been given a list of reporters to
call on and uh they asked him about it
you would say no no it's my list yeah
I made it because he understands that
you don't want to look like a puppet no
moving
yeah make sure you make sure you keep an
eye on him they're quarterback yeah uh
and then uh I I'm I'm staring right at
his Muppets
it's distracting yes it's right looking
at me no that's good keep saying Muppet
penis that's YouTube guidelines is that
not is that against YouTube guidelines
no no Muppet penis is perfectly fine oh
that's crazy but
but it's look it's a puppet yeah
former Vice President Joe Biden uh also
confused Putin with President Trump uh I
caught part of president's uh Trump uh
Putin's uh uh press conference and he
talked about the need for us to be able
to have some kind of modus operandi we
dealt with making sure the Arctic was in
fact a free zone
um I mean it makes sense because he
checks under his bed for both
he's so boring they put him on C-Span
three
I didn't even know there was a C-SPAN
what's C-SPAN two uh Buffalo Wild Wings
cornhole championships
it's the Red Bull BMX off a cliff event
how about Joe Biden that'd be
interesting he thinks that whatever
Putin says is is Gospel yeah like do you
not understand he's like oh yeah it's
gonna totally be a free zone they got a
lot of Warships up there and they're
taking our land but don't worry he
probably said yeah there's gonna be a
free zone yeah yeah by the way we got to
talk about what you did to a masseuse
earlier yeah well we actually shouldn't
because we're well within YouTube okay
but uh he also this is something that's
really important here this is again a
complete lack of accountability that
President uh former Vice President Joe
Biden um he lives in he lives in a
bubble where he is hermetically sealed
from any any sort of criticism or
accountability it's not that he says
this it's not that he openly spouts a
lie sort of like I've used this as a
quintessential example because Barack
Obama went out and cited the women make
77 cents on the dollar which was
complete lie feminism it's it's it's a
myth it's dishonest and any Economist
Worth or salt will tell you it's
completely untrue right because if it
were true I would hire only women yeah
so what a lot of I get to pay less and
more boobs it's two wins but it doesn't
work that way and you go wait hold on a
second does Barack Obama not have Google
or does he know that it's a lie right
and I think now they're just so
complacent uh they are so comfortable
with the media carrying their water that
Joe Biden doesn't realize that even the
media is going to have to backtrack now
and address the lie that he spouts on
January 6th uh and uh saying that the
rioters killed an officer which we know
is not true when President Putin was
questioned today about human rights he
said the reason why he's cracking down
on opposition leaders
um is because he doesn't want something
like January 6 to happen in Russia and
he also says he doesn't want to see
groups formed like black lives matter
what's your response to that please
my response is kind of what I
communicated but I think that's a
that's a ridiculous comparison it's one
thing for literally criminals
to break through Cordon go into the
capital kill a police officer did not be
held unaccountable you are fake it is
for people objecting marching on a
Capital One saying you are not allowing
me to speak freely you are not allowing
me to do A B C or D and so they're very
different criteria okay
um this is something if if you if people
were to want if the if the left were to
want a Civil War which God forbid ever
happens in this country right this is
how you do it this is how you do it what
you do is tell Americans that what they
are seeing what they are experiencing at
least two billion dollars in Damages
it's been a year since they've uh
they've upped the number since they've
updated it probably four billion and
we're talking about the black lives
matter right cities burning dozens of
deaths hundreds of Officer casualties
City Halls Walgreens police precincts
being burned right right in front of
their eyes people being shot in
autonomous zones that were erected in a
complete state of lawlessness and you
say all they were doing was saying that
they weren't allowed to speak as opposed
to January 6th and then you'll lie and
say where someone killed an officer if
you want this is sort of exactly if you
look at the Playbook of people who want
to create civil unrest division within
their country they used to accuse Donald
Trump of this yeah what you do is tell
people that exactly what they are seeing
and experiencing isn't so
that's how that's how civil war starts
yeah well and you're empowering a a
foreign Dictator by saying there's a
January 6th Riot that happens and 800
people I think Max is what they're
saying got out of control out of 200
000. 400 is what I'm here yeah 400 are
getting arrested I think there's more
coming from the FBI but now Vladimir
Putin just said
I watch CNN today they said there was an
Insurrection I don't want that here and
so that's why I have a guy in prison and
that's why I'm just is that not the
story that's the story of the entire
conference for me right that's
justifying it because you guys are
overplaying your hand and saying oh it
was an Insurrection but Burning Down the
damn courthouse in Seattle over and over
and over again isn't yeah that's totally
fine possible yeah well the tactic is
actually manipulation and abuse by
making people think that what they see
isn't actually there and what they
remember isn't true right it's
unbelievable yes I can't I can't believe
no no one is covering that part of the
story saying oh my gosh they just use
this again no they should maybe we
should walk it back a little bit they
try to ask Putin tough questions and and
basically it was so you uh foreign
[Laughter]
of course we are not implying that any
elections have ever been stolen no never
never vote whatsoever Amy clebuchar was
wrong Jimmy Carter was wrong yes can we
say Russia I'm trying to think Elizabeth
Warren was wrong Bernie Sanders was
wrong yeah they were there has never
been an example of it I just want to be
crystal clear that was just a joke from
Medusa yes can we say that the Russian
election was is there can we say
anything about that I don't know it
depends on how many YouTube users there
are in Russia that day yeah it's still
questionable so here we're just standing
here's the next quote where I thought
because we didn't watch all of this live
I thought this was a fake headline I
thought it was like the Babylon B you
know my antenna always go up I mostly
read liberal sources because I want to
be informed as to what the other side is
saying so when I read something that
seems so mind-numbingly stupid I said
well no no no sitting member of office
of our higher Halls
would say something like that no he
actually did so um he actually laid out
critical parts of infrastructure yeah
that were off limits I think he gave a
number later I think he said like 16 16.
16 items I told Putin that these 16
items are off limits I made a list no no
president would make a list of 16
implying that
everything other than the 16 is not off
limits dude a sitting president wouldn't
do that right was sitting you know
former vice president believe you're
lying eyes and ears I talked about the
proposition that certain critical
infrastructure should be off limits to
attack period
my side or any other means I gave them a
list if I'm not mistaken if I don't have
it in front of me 16 specific entities
and I feel like Putin's sitting over
there like this he's like
take some notes here okay so uh Bob
Evans between Florida and six okay got
it all right
he puts on his anonymous mask yeah
remember remember yeah I would never
want you to actually bomb this
infrastructure
I mean here's the thing and I understand
the left is trying to carry his water
saying well no he was trying to say with
those those are red lines okay here's my
question does that mean if you screw
with these 16 pieces of infrastructure
that are critical that we go to war is
that what he's saying right because
that's not a red line that Joe Biden
will enforce oh and is he saying so
outside of these 16 you know they're off
limits but it's not a an immediate call
to war any way you slice it it's a
really bad thing to do right exactly and
by the way if you aren't prepared to
have some kind of massive Force back
this up and you say okay look 16 things
fine if you go after any of this stuff
this is going to happen don't pull what
Obama did with Syria don't go and say
this is the red line and then back off
because Putin will never respect you
doesn't in the first no it's anyway you
meant Libya ah but no that's right for
people former former Vice President Joe
Biden uh confused Syria with Libya there
yeah three times whoops three times once
with labia yes I got it on the brain
a secret it doesn't work Snake Island
lesbian Island there's all kinds of
diffuser again comparing it to Donald
Trump Pablo Island can anyone say that
Donald Trump did anything other than
either keep his cards close to his chest
or just lie to throw you off he played
that's what he would do Putin like would
you do one with a glass of water no I've
actually I was born with a genetic and
I'm I don't even need water always
hydrated barely need sleep yeah it's
weird
what
I missed Trump can you imagine like what
17 was like ah geez it was aoc's
building across from number six oh okay
gotcha yeah
16 and I was 17 and I have PTSD and he
just died I was in Vermont during 9 11.
17 was Ben and Jerry's I was that close
to being there okay no snow I want to
wash my hands my hair and face with oh
my God
Ben and Jerry's they've jumped on the
bandwagon yeah yeah it's always nice
short and curly in your pint yes my
favorite flavor is Rudy Tootie Justified
shooties
no unjustified oh yeah oh unjustified
you're right I forget it's still tasty
yeah it still is I like gummy tears
oh that was now here's what's also
here's what's also really pretty uh
funny uh Joe Biden gets really upset
about something that should be a
compliment in this next clip yeah so the
person is trying to give him the benefit
of the doubt going like yeah so you're
in you know you're and he's like ah I
didn't say that I didn't say I was
confident what ah so this is where uh
someone asked him about his confidence
and he just says no I never said I was
confident yeah I I suck here you go why
are you so confident he'll change his
behavior Mr President yeah
I'm so indignant about it it's kind of
straight I said what will change their
behavior is in the rest of the world
reacts to them and it diminishes their
stand into the world I'm not confident
of anything
we are away don't insinuate capability
every response he has reminds me of that
uh like a diabetes commercial where it's
like if I don't take my insulin I get
real short with my family
he just gets mad somebody
's Snickers yeah yeah if you're not
yourself and then we need some Snickers
he's just as well or he just someone
accidentally hands him a Mars bar and he
becomes more [ __ ]
it's like the last scene in big in his
suit
yeah it's like oh yeah let me guess Baby
Ruth
ah someone get the EpiPen oh
price went up when I came in somebody
asked me a question I got irate they
said a good thing I know they didn't
tell us to be a part of the job uh so
you let me know again you can come up
what did you honestly objectively we we
got Flack for being objective about
President Trump within and I said I
don't like Putin I don't like that he's
even seeming complimentary but if you
look he was harder on Putin we got upset
with him and Kim Jong-un until he walked
away with nothing and people were giving
us Flack and you know what I will say
the the end net result
ended up being better what do you see
what do you see down the road here um
let us know and of course uh this has
been this week in Biden if you have a
problem figuring out whether you're for
me or Trump and you ain't black
uh what's going on here on C is that
tubing is on CNN oh my gosh oh look at
his shoulders are so tense watching you
over this looks like he hasn't relaxed
in a while no he certainly isn't that
opportunity now to build on it hear high
is voices yeah Supreme Court Obamacare
is that not too bad
it was on like a second ago oh well
maybe he wasn't really this guy yeah
that looks like a larger version it does
look like can someone bring up a picture
they had tubing up in this corner and
then that guy red blood so that's weird
can someone bring up a picture of tubing
so we can put it side by side with this
guy because I'm not convinced that
that's just not tubing stung by a pieces
this is like somebody that ate tubing
maybe tubing's allergic to a new kind of
Ky he bought
am I right right no okay
Jeff organic doesn't mean it's
hypoallergenic water-based water-based
I thought we were at a commercial uh all
right well before you guys are finding
the tube in picture this actually all
right so come on that's just that tube
really cool that's just fat tubing
they'll probably put those two in the
same frame again if they do it look yeah
they can get my attention I will drop
everything like a Spot the Difference
his name is Jeffrey tuba
I just it it seems like like if they
were twins he was the twin who kind of
shoved him out yeah yeah placenta
I can't that's not tubing oh my gosh I
thought I right when you went to what I
thought it was too watch people will say
oh look fake news no I look I apologize
wrong I got it wrong I just they're
talking legal issues so it makes sense
that's what he comes on to talk about
look I just think all white people look
alike and that's my fault come on let's
not act like every other CNN Banker's
weight doesn't yo-yo yeah it's not like
it'd be it's not like it'd be
unfathomable
no no I think our statue was finally by
the way this is what we're talking about
Joy this hasn't been covered anywhere
um you know he he didn't do very well
yesterday and this is after keeping
context he cleared the day Tuesday
basically did nothing to rest up because
he had a really bad day Monday so Monday
bad Tuesday recoup Wednesday oh and I
thought Monday was bad and
um I I no one else has been covering
this but uh we found out that why the
remember the pregnant person's pause
yeah that happened that was really long
well we know why there was there was
someone in his earpiece thank you
um
in a weekend interview Vladimir Putin
laughed at the suggestion that you had
called him a killer is that still your
belief sir that he is a killer and what
do you say to Vladimir Putin
to answer the first question
[Laughter]
I'm laughing too
I am in control room well look I mean he
is made clear that uh
[Laughter]
shameful man I just don't like that he
gets one over on her yeah sitting former
vice president I wonder if they know he
knows his earpiece is that loud I don't
know
I'm surprised I'm surprised it doesn't
have a two foot dial pad
it's a rotary
did it full oh by the way hey if you're
notification Bell uh because
subscriptions don't mean a whole lot
right now doesn't really work and we're
a live show Monday through Thursday you
know just at 10 A.M Eastern hey can we
tell them to smash that like button yeah
oh Smash It Do It smash It smash It
smash [ __ ] like button
speaking of mash no moving Tourette's
intern
what's it watching you man is it okay uh
this is something that a lot of people
are not covering and I want to know if
you guys have actually so you remember
that there was a press conference for
people this happened while we were live
on air and and sometimes you know things
sort of happen on air keep in mind I'm
looking at a small monitor so I didn't
realize how impactful it was and just
the level of the pardon me the [ __ ]
that was being peddled until I had some
quiet time yeah had a nice cigar and
then went to whitehouse.gov and I pulled
a Biden really yeah [ __ ] my pants ah
yeah it'll happen because it is
terrified like I watched a gay Tick-Tock
clown yes
who for some reason has a very elegant
home yes very nice that's got to be
inherited good for him all that money
can't be made accepting applications
[Laughter]
really depends what a horrible person I
know I'm accepting applications to be
gay and what you're now implying it's a
choice I don't understand I also don't
understand how you're how you're born
gay but you choose your gender well are
you also born a clown because that's
what they look like also why the Geisha
fan
just pick something
stick with it it's enough consistency
they only get away with it because if we
had a geisha fan yeah it'd be front page
it'd be front page oh yeah it matters
they got mad they got mad yesterday that
I said uh I said uh women shouldn't
comment on men's sports if they get mad
about Charles Barkley San Antonio
the one thing they took from this it's
the least serious thing I said I was on
the German uh Mike show Mike passed way
a little while ago but Drew's a huge fan
of you yesterday a huge fan of you great
it's a great show if anybody listens and
uh he was even reading the stuff that
Media Matters is written by us and I
love when somebody's reading it and it's
funny in print yeah
it's like this was what you went for to
detract people from watching us it's an
ad every one of those are yes it's
fantastic all his way left and right all
right so going back to domestic Terrors
and by the way do you know who the
domestic terrorists are the number one
threat yeah
oh yeah I know you think black lives
matter no yeah if uh months and months
Isis sleeper cells John's next door oh
yeah no no no no no
it's the folks with uh it's the folks
with an AR and a pickup truck ah so
here's those American flags yeah here's
U.S attorney Merrick Garland who I don't
like but I do appreciate that they I do
appreciate the player on this one that
they put it in after this guy was denied
yeah like all right we're gonna back to
him and like uh good play a lot but I
don't like it
he announced the White House the new
plans to focus on domestic terrorism and
specifically they keep using the term
and highlighting the greatest threat to
American society white supremacist here
the number of open FBI domestic
terrorism investigations this year has
increased significantly
according to an unclassified summary of
the March intelligence assessment the
two most lethal elements of the domestic
violence extremist threat are racially
or ethnically motivated violent
extremists and militia violent
extremists in the FBI's view the top
domestic violent extremist threat comes
from racially or ethnically motivated
violent extremists specifically those
who advocated for the superiority of the
white race okay look it's stupid on TV
that's 2 Reuben that's skinny tubing see
wow they really just let him right back
on yep think about you tell me that he
did not look like the other guy whose
name I don't even know look like fat
tubing the other guy was fat or tubing
it's like I don't know which one to
shoot
I would never shoot anything with no
laser gun yeah
right you know where like a metal
spiders came up and some uh bald lady
kept going
exactly it's got us that that said come
on now that's uh uh um Minority Report
is just ruined by that woman oh oh the
Oracle yeah what was it what was the
audition called hey come on here yeah
will you shave your head and can you go
I don't know you're hired wonderful
how do you feel about uh sitting in a
moat because Tom Cruise will be next to
you so
um
I cannot believe that they allow tubing
back on this is a man masturbated in
front of his co-workers and he's talking
to three women yeah yeah let's put him
on the show with uh chicks this is a
good idea Louis CK goes near a comedy
club and it's the end of the world this
guy's sitting here giving his opinion
the truth is it's pretty much the same
thing only Louis CK asked
which is which is weird don't get me
wrong right yeah but he had permission
but not I thought it was all about
consent even Janine Garofalo and Sarah
Silverman who are huge liberals went it
came and defended Louis they were like
he asked
which is still weird I mean I'm not
saying yeah I don't know how I would
broach the question I'd be like hey you
wanna you wanna get sick
to throw up yeah you want to see me do
something gross you're not using that
lunch yet earlier yeah you're fine right
good you want to look what's gonna
resemble an old woman feeding Birds yeah
that's for my ACT sorry it was good I
just look disgusting when I okay
so the White House here's what's also
important the White House released
talking points for the new domestic
terrorism policy and I I I would be
playing it down if I said that it's a
little concerning yes so a senior
Administration press call from Tuesday
included a section that read one of the
things we're talking about is the need
to do something in this space like the
see something if you see something say
something concept that has been
promulgated previously by DHS did I
pronounce that correctly did yes yes DHS
yeah I can never say Pete dazek
Properties
or Star Wars huh is he pasaki's cousin
so this is this involves creating
context in which those who are family
members or friends or co-workers know
that there are Pathways and avenues to
raise concerns and seek help for those
they have perceived to be radicalizing
and potentially radicalizing toward
violence oh sounds a little bit like
communism exactly turn in your family
members that is the most vague you
perceive them to be radical yes or to be
tending towards now here's the thing if
that existed in a vacuum
if that existed in a vacuum you say well
okay they obviously mean right
terrorists they mean you know like the
people who commit the mass the serious
majority of terrorism globally right in
the name of a political prescription
that is Islam uh no because then when
you read the entire context at
whitehouse.gov you see them reiterate
what they really mean and this is one
thing too I think people sometimes uh
are focusing I don't want to say
focusing on the wrong thing but
sometimes they they in just discussing
critical race Theory it makes people
think that it's only a problem uh that
occurs in schools right and this has
something pretty familiar with you know
critical race Theory Black Liberation
theology and even the differences there
and it's basically just cultural Marxism
because Andrew Breitbart while he was
alive and I I uh you know used to
contribute at Big Hollywood
um he brought up the video of Barack
Obama's Professor Derek Bell yeah and
talked about critical race Theory this
is something that's been going on for a
long time now I need you to sort of take
that lens pull it out a little bit
critical race Theory starts with
something racist Equity the goal is not
equality the goal is equity if someone
tells you that we must ensure Equity
that person is a racist and I'll explain
what I mean as I read down that's not
hyperbole
so uh the White House their fact sheet
now that they have at whitehouse.gov it
says it found that I mean this report
the most lethal element of today's
domestic terrorism threat are racially
or ethnically motivated violent
extremists who advocate for the
superiority of the white race okay hold
on a second
again we just talked about black lives
matter right we just talked about these
protests we talked about antifa we
talked about billions of dollars in
Damages okay dozens of deaths I know I'm
repeating myself ad nauseum but just so
I drive that point home now let's take
the worst example they have
that you have the capital what you guys
call the Insurrection yeah
any evidence that that was inspired by
white supremacy
white supremacists generally don't want
to as you described it hang Mike Pence
the man is as white as you can GI Joe
thinks it's extreme right Nancy Pelosi
also white they didn't like her either
so in other words what examples can you
point a team as far as that even is
comparable that it is the single
greatest threat
I need them that I I can't believe that
they're actually with a straight face
making the argument that we need to
that's white house.gov could be a game
well yeah exactly that's right I never
know we need to Discount the entire year
that we just had in fact it's a year
that Vladimir Vladimir Putin just said
we don't want black lives matter forming
here well what is he talking about
because apparently that was just the
Summer of Love
if Vladimir Putin can see the coverage
and go wow that's terrible yeah we don't
want something like that in Russia
shouldn't that tell you that maybe
you've missed it maybe you know who
didn't think a Summer of Love was it
Seattle police chief of Portland uh
police chief the black lady I'm horrible
yeah I think I believe it was
yeah she's heard of Woodstock yeah we
all remember Jim Croce stomping A store
owner to death right right it's just
it's unreal and all the antiva stuff and
even if you just isolated to Portland
yeah just the stuff they've done in
Portland that's a terrorist act I would
never understand you took over six city
blocks of a major city you handed out
AR-15s illegally to minors and this is
really real people get me on board with
hating an AR-15 story congratulations
exactly yeah you did it you've committed
a miracle
next the Olive Garden never-ending pasta
I don't know how they do it
you asked a really good question how in
the world do you think these people were
white supremacists you know why because
they were Trump supporters that's the
narrative you support Trump you are
foreign
and they shot people yes and didn't
allow Medics to come in and treat the
people who were shot and they're pissed
about it and didn't the guy who was
running the whole thing have like a
grant from the government yeah for his
Studio he did we're still banned from
Airbnb uh so this is also on what else
dot gov there factsheet DOD
d-o-g-a-d-o-d-d-o-j well this this thing
should be DOA
DOD doj and I'm in a correction and DHS
are similarly pursuing efforts to ensure
domestic terrorists are not employed so
now we said greatest threat white
supremacist how many times have they
said on CNN the white supremacist
faction of the Republican Party the
Trump faction exactly right that's one
and the same they're going to make sure
you're not employed so a Maga hat might
lead to you think of the Black Mirror
episode which actually happens in China
by the way who are not paying attention
to for some reason a social credit score
no no that person's a white supremacist
and we all see now that you have what
you have people from the capitol uh
January 6th from the events that happen
in the capital who have this is a fact
no more charges than trespassing and
they've been held indefinitely you don't
think they'd be willing to lock you up
for a Twitter post or at the very least
make sure you can't make a living you
want to act like this doesn't happen
right now this is basically uh
legalization it's it's a legal
recognition a legal method a mechanism
to incorporate the cancel map yeah
because right now it happens on social
media but they want to make sure that
the White House has the final say here's
how this phone call would go hi I'm
Gerald's brother he supports Donald
Trump because he voted for him he's a
republican he went to a trump rally and
he actually has a sticker on his car
that says support the police I think you
should come get him yes all of that
would be enough to consider me
potentially a radical you've been
tapping my phone exactly because then my
racial credit score is going to be like
two
I'm kids
Uber yeah oh to be fun yeah well this is
just the dumbest thing imaginable it's
scary it really is scary because it
makes no sense well it makes perfect
sense when you unders look it makes
perfect sense when you have to under you
have to take into account I never want
to be in the business of attributing
motives in this case go to
whitehouse.gov go to the link in the
description if you're on YouTube right
now we provide all of our references or
as young kids say sources we used to say
references back in the days
bibliographies read the whole thing I'm
not attributing motive here they're very
clear about it
okay they're very clear about what this
is let me read the rest to you uh so you
understand the totality because there's
also an association with a foreign
entity here which is a problem when you
understand what they're about again keep
in mind the United States is the only
place with the First Amendment and
there's no way to just do away with that
right but there are ways to chip that so
the United States also joined the Christ
Church call to action to eliminate
terrorist and violent extremist content
online in international partnership
between governments and technology
companies now if that doesn't scare you
yet let me show you Merrick Garland
talking about Christ Church in his
speech and then explain to you what they
are about in dictating American policy
the technology sector is particularly
important to countering terrorist abuse
of internet-based communication
platforms to recruit and cite plot
attacks or foment hatred along with more
than 50 other countries the United
States has joined the Christ Church call
to action
to collaborate with each other and
relevant stakeholders including tech
companies ngos and academics to tackle
the online aspects of this Threat all
right and you want to know why I'm
really pissed off with Republicans and
you want the most disappointing thing
that ever happened with President Donald
Trump is they didn't do anything about
the big Tech censorship and really a
trip opoly they didn't do it they had
the time they held hearings they didn't
do anything now we're hoping for States
like Florida and Texas and other other
states to hopefully follow suit because
now you see the other guys are in charge
and they're coming for all of it yeah
you heard him say that tech companies
and let me read you about the Christ
Church call this is from their website
counter the drivers this is their
mission statement I guess like Jerry
Maguire wrote it at midnight in a laptop
counter it's a memo it's a mission
statement counter the drivers of
terrorism and violent extremism by
strengthening the resilience and
inclusiveness of our societies to enable
them to resist terrorist and violent
extremist ideologies what's the greatest
among those right now white supremacy it
was a white supremacist anyone who votes
for Donald Trump including the black
ones I'm looking at you Candace
including through education building
media literacy to help counter distorted
terrorist and violent extremist
narratives and fight against inequality
so that seems vague enough very very
yeah until you go down and you see oh
hold on a second now they're carving it
in
accelerate Research into and development
of Technical Solutions to prevent the
upload of and to detect and immediately
remove terrorist and violent extremist
content now let's be clear what's that
is that defined as black lives matter is
that defined as burn a cop car is that
defined as looting only 949 from
Walgreens is that defined as shooting
David Dorne
we just need no no of course listen to
the New Zealand prime minister uh I
don't know how to say Jacinda I don't
know how they say it Peter Jackson yeah
explaining the Christ Church call back
in 2019 then we'll come back to the
States I'm on my way to a gathering of
world leaders and tech companies and
Civil Society in Paris to promote
something called the Christchurch what
happened in Christchurch was unique in
one particular way
this was a terrorist act that was
designed to go viral and we're left
there for with I think a sense of
responsibility a duty of care to try and
use prevent terrorist attacks like this
ever happening on our soil again but to
also try and prevent that sharing of
terrorist content of extreme violent
content online
so that's what the Christchurch call is
all about now we as a government we've
kind of Simply set back and within New
Zealand formulated our own regulatory
response but social media companies
these platforms they're Global and so
the response needs to be Global and that
is what is so terrifying their Global
and guess what they're beholden to other
Global entities be there be them
governments or be them Partnerships like
the Christ Church call to action
conference whatever the thing is called
if I get it right the doctor where none
of them have the First Amendment none of
them have the first amendment I come
from Canada we actually were about to
have a pastor on who's he's currently in
jail for hosting an outdoor service wow
after some of the restrictions were
lifted but you still couldn't have a
service outside right people understand
and you'll get people in New Zealand in
Australia by the way we're still funnier
than the net who then say okay oh yeah
and she hates tourists right apparently
there is who then say that uh well I
don't feel like my rights are infringed
you hear that in Canada I don't you
never do until you need them exactly you
never feel like your rights are
infringed until you try to worship until
you try to say something that's
unpopular the First Amendment doesn't
exist for the speech that we all agree
is permissible it exists specifically
for offensive speech and let me be
really clear here people say well how do
you how do you uh how do you set up a
boundaries right that's the big
psychological term nowadays um the law
call to actual actions of violence are
illegal threats of violence are illegal
we already have those laws there is no
reason to expand it unless the goal is
to control speech which by the way right
after adopting to Christchurch call New
Zealand uh they banned the uh the
website Han
try the service provider yeah the
service provider for it well they also
if you read that document really early
on they acknowledge that this is going
to look like a grab at freedom of
expression and freedom of speech around
the world and they're like no no this is
totally not we understand that you have
to be able to do that and then they
Define this this hate speech thing right
this word it has no definition they
Define it so loosely it is whatever they
say it is and by the way I'm not going
to go into any details on this so this
is not dangerous territory just to do a
Google search on New Zealand coveted
lockdowns just look at what New Zealand
has done in this last year and a half
and then tell me you want them leading
the world's response well what do you
mean people have to do their own work
Danny Zuko yeah that's because we're
kids we're making them go somewhere else
do they own work all right maybe maybe
they do it what they do there in New
Zealand huh cheap yeah
don't knock it till you tried it I said
I didn't say anything about it
in a white country
[Laughter]
deprecation is self humiliation yeah
yeah kind of yeah that's kind of what it
is it's called humor well I don't like
it well then get off the stage oh you're
not funny
well that's your opinion no it's
everyone's opinion not named The New
York Times right so this is also
important to know who else has signed on
to this Christ Church call uh Brooking
institution Brookings institution who of
course supports suppressing speech let
me read you from Brookings institution
on January 6 2021 president Trump gave
an incendiary speech to supporters
telling them to fight like hell so right
away they start with a lie they don't
include the peacefully made and then
they what is the conclusion what is the
call to action here from Brookings for
now it is vital for social media
companies to be vigilant in stopping
violent rhetoric and for law enforcement
to anticipate and quickly suppress
violence before it spreads uh that's
where we are actually that is actually a
Minority Report territory it is it is
anticipated yes absolutely it is so how
do you anticipate and and stop violence
before it spreads what if somebody's out
there just you know making a case that
uh that they like one guy over another
guy in an election is that do you need
to stop that person because now every
one of their supporters is racist and
obviously an extremist listen this is a
good question you have to say Okay what
is the barometer for them what's the
limit test well they already just showed
their hand in that Donald Trump saying
fight like hell and we showed you guys a
video where pretty much every single
member of Congress the Senate has used
that in some speech at some point at
least hundreds over the last decade and
they want you to believe that that is a
call to I mean break through a window
and not kill any officers at the at the
Capitol and by the way to go to the Alex
Jones thing this was also circulating
this week and you guys know I've had
Alex Jones on the show I probably
disagree with Alex Jones on more than I
agree with them and frankly sometimes I
think that ah he's danced on the line
and I've talked about that but because
people who always say oh that person
went over the line when they're talking
about cancel culture until eventually
that line comes for them I've just
always drawn that line unless it's
against the law you have to permit it
they tried to spread the rumor that oh
Alex Jones was in direct communication
with the White House house so they
planned the capital Insurrection and
paid 500 000 to do it right one story
too yeah of course because they're gonna
trust Alex Jones with that
so I didn't mean
Alex can you keep your mouth shut oh no
everyone knows that about me president
Trump there's no possible way he said
get the bullhorn up listen if this money
could get any strings attached that I
need to not tell everybody that's gonna
be a problem the frogs are gay
but there's footage of Alex Jones saying
stop stop they want you to do this go
away from the capitol he was on our show
and said it was one of the worst days of
his life because even if you can draw an
association between the White House and
Alex Jones Alex Jones was not there
encouraging violence no but the media
doesn't tell that half of the story so
for sure they would put Alex Jones on a
list to be unemployed to be on a
terrorist watch list do we not have
lawyers in the United States is there
not someone who's an adult that can be
specific about what these things mean
are we just going to have laws that are
so vague that they can't be enforced or
they can just be abused whenever they
want yeah they're taking notes from
YouTube with your feedback no no they
will not be specific other supporters by
the way include the dangerous speech
project for the Christchurch call and
life after hate and let's go back to the
whitehouse.gov here which how do you say
that in Greek
I was just stuck on life after hate yeah
I didn't
mean anything it sounds like a Hillary
Duff PSA doesn't it remember when she
said uh she did that PSA she's like when
you say that's gay do you know what you
say yes why don't you tell me then she
shames the girl she's like well what if
I called that dress skinny gross [ __ ]
you're like this isn't you're like this
this is just you mocking her for
something else it really does really
change and she started lifting weights I
know wow I prefer the sister with the
schnoz take it take them Feats back to
Nickelodeon
White House agenda again at
whitehouse.gov it shows direct influence
from Christ Church look this is this is
what they say here every component of
the government has a role to play in
rooting out racism
okay and bigotry now we're getting into
really vague territory and advancing
equity for all Americans I have an
honest question yeah is racism illegal
it's you know that's a good question I
think we all agree that racism is
abhorrent but no it's not a crime no
like I think it's wrong
you're right Maxine Waters would be
locked up for crying out loud so why are
there so many laws based on a thing
that's not a crime right now what is a
crime that's a very good point I know
what is a crime assaulting someone
because of their race yes it is
murdering someone but here's the beauty
a hate doesn't need a footnote no crime
is just a back door and it's like oh
murder is the crime that's the main one
yeah do most murders happen because you
love someone
you need to throw the hate the
definition
like Selena yeah that's true
she's like I love you so much I gotta
kill you oh yeah people do that people
they do no one in this room no no but
you're absolutely it's not illegal so
that's also why it's important they say
every component of the government has a
role to play in rooting out racism first
off it's not illegal it's horrible of
course yeah we have an incredibly
diverse group of people here if they
were rooting if they were rooting out
racism we'd be skimmed over like we
painted Lamb's Blood on the top why
would you want Koreans we have Japanese
we have black people we have everyone
Latinos it makes me uncomfortable of all
the countries are you choosing the
Melting Pot to be the racist
and the word Equity this is something
that is the for everything for critical
racer because what is critical racer you
have to look at the end game nonsense is
well 1619 it's the United States really
only started with slavery right
therefore we need to rectify that and
Ensure
Equity Equity is the it's a synonym for
equal outcomes yep that's exactly what
it is and here's the thing you cannot
have equality of opportunity it's not
possible equality of opportunity and
Equity it is one or the other let me
explain to you why if you say oh well we
need uh 25
of Harvard admissions to be black you go
well just there aren't enough who have
this SAT score and look there's this
agent no no got to be 25 you are now
forbidding equality of opportunity when
you set quotas when you say that there
has to be a guaranteed percentage look
at the lawsuits with Asian Americans I
believe it's Harvard Brown there are a
few going on right now that is an
example of guaranteed Equity it is
racism by definition because it excludes
People based on race and the government
is saying white supremacy is a threat
and we are going to try and guarantee
Equity with every it says every
component of the government you know
what that means that doesn't just mean
government agencies that means if you do
business with the government or you
supply a business that does business
with the government their hands reach
all the way down and all that oh oh
you're not fighting the way we want you
to fight uh this this problem of racism
in the country we're no longer doing
business with you your government
contracts in this year yeah well that
quality would be giving everybody the
same chance not lowering the bar well
that's so Thomas or setting different
bars for different people yeah he is
racism yeah component of government
going to root that out yeah Thomas Soul
has a really good point on this he says
look if you can't guarantee equal
outcomes for siblings that are in the
same house with the same parents with
the same opportunities how can you
possibly do anything in the world when
it's not nearly that comparable right
you can't do it this happened I mean uh
well Troy Junior our other statutory you
went to you went to NYU or was it
Columbia
that's okay you can was it NYU or
Columbia
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
a guy I knew used to do a thing called
when he was like 15 and I just been
middle of a conversation just grab a
breast and I'd be like I have no control
over this go on but it was my friend's
[ __ ] they all thought it was funny yeah
yeah sensual
my hand has a mind of it I'm like I'm
like this isn't me you just have to let
it do its thing no that's my love free
Devon sour Idle Hands or uh it's
probably where I got it yeah it was
still fun to do yeah it only works if
you looked like Devin Sawa in 97. that's
a good thing oh this was pre okay all
right well then Devin Sawa he he's still
for me yeah he I was doing this since
95. that and departed down the middle I
had that too A thieving son of a [ __ ]
hey by the way if you're watching this
live right now hit the share button
because sharing is caring that means you
can share it on Facebook on Twitter and
it just real with pride it grinds the
gears of people at Big Tech because it
puts it right at the top of the Live
Life share it oh by the way it's time to
go actually I guess we really quickly we
have to uh talk about one of our
sponsors we have a video here wonderful
sponsor Spartan armor on the Range I'm
about to shoot stuff and blow it up all
right we're about to test out the new
Spartan armor plate the Hercules level
four and uh the reason Spartan created
this plate is that a lot of those out
there the competitors they'll say
they're 10 by 12 but they don't really
cover the whole area so spark number
wanted to design a plate that truly
covers 10 by 12 level four so I believe
30.6 uh armor piercing rounds it's
approved up to that but we're just going
to be using the uh
you know basic but scary Black Rifle
AR-15 uh today to see if it holds up to
it and let's see if
my half asian lawyer was right to not
be shot live in the studio with the
plate he thought that was ill-advised
[Music]
hey don't try this at home unless your
home is a range but do use the promo
code Crowder at spartanarmersystems.com
for 10 off Crowder 10 off and uh
look at that that's like uh that's
that's less that's less tattered than uh
than uh Brendan's jeans
he bought them that way
[Music]
yeah look at this thing go to uh and we
have a we have a full segment coming out
ah where I shot this thing is that the
one you shot yeah oh nice yeah well you
can see because one time I accidentally
shot it in the side here and it still
didn't go through oh wow that's cool but
I shot it I shot it wrong in the side
and just kind of went in and got lost
now I'm not saying it's not gonna it's
not gonna feel like a pillow fight
yeah but you'll still be alive yeah you
can't even see all the all the handgun
stuff the only thing you can see is
where I had horrible aim with the rifle
uh and you just go to
smartnumbersystems.com use a promo code
Crowder you get 10 off oh nice that's
what I'm wearing right now just because
I didn't want to be nude today I said I
better either put on nipple pasties or
uh is it pasties or pasties did you have
like oh pasties is the northern Michigan
dish that yeah it's basically a Hot
Pocket yeah you don't want to put those
on your nose no no that's a problem you
don't want to pull a Cuomo come on
fantastic
just stringy hot cheese
oh venison nips
clamp it clap it
it's in the mind just like just blow it
up
don't wait for me so I'm gonna rolled up
dollars just like oh right
I guess you have changed yeah it is true
for people people out there you guys
people who are from Michigan especially
Northern Michigan if you guys know do
you guys know what pasties are no it's
like a it's basically sort of like a
meat pie Hot Pocket yeah
um and uh it was what the miners just
use and you can just leave that there
and I'll grab it a little after uh I'll
grab it after you just leave it on the
floor or something or if you want to
bring it in yeah just bring it in and
over here thank you thank you she's out
of costume all right get out of here and
keep your complimentary comments to
yourself YouTube jerks even the nice
comments are just gross
um there's a lot of lonely men out but
pasties the first time you have it it
really is it's it's just you will not
taste anything for a month oh no it just
burns wait what it's basically like the
miners in northern Michigan people out
there like come on you got to tell me I
think Jenny's is a place in northern
Michigan it's like famous for pasties
it's just they put in like rutabaga meat
they're in the U.P yeah in the U.P and
it was what they would use when they
were mining it was just like a pocket of
food like the original Hot Pocket
and you couldn't taste for a while
because when the burst Burns it stays
hot for so long yeah
I thought it was like spice hot no no no
no no no no they wouldn't even put an
onion in there yeah like they must have
a special oven which is why they they
still exist right they're like well we
inherited this it's all we can make yeah
but they give it to you and it doesn't
feel hot until you boy you take that
bite and you're just like oh it's gonna
look like I have herpes for the next
time my face is on fire gonna sound like
because I have herpes well that's true
yeah you're like oh I've been eating all
these pasties you want a kiss
they're not a good driving food either I
found that out no they're not but you
would think the pocket is why I bought
it and now I'm like wow my seat's ruin
my these jeans I might as well throw
away my car's upside down all right dude
yeah
very good Gerald uh hey by the way oh
you're supposed to eat us yes foreign
[Laughter]
remember body control stay in neutral a
lot of people don't realize this
actually we uh that statues that in
ancient Greece
um they actually have very strong views
this is not a joke about the males
genitalia right and culturally it this
had a strong influence over Society so
here to explain it to us actually is a
professor penis
[Music]
okay well thank you Professor penis
thank you for being here sir yeah thanks
for having me back and you're just to be
clear you this is you are an actual
scientist you studied this yeah yep I'm
a scientist of penis and penis related
uh Sciences yeah okay so um yeah no
listen this is uh and thank God back
then there was no affirmative he got it
on his on his Merit yeah yeah let me ask
you can you set this up for people who
don't know the the Greek historical uh
actually the context of how they viewed
penises because a lot of the statues
we've everyone has noticed they're
they're relatively they're they're small
they're a little yeah petite okay so
yeah this is actually as you mentioned
this is one of the considered one of the
greatest anthropological and art history
kind of anomalies like okay so the
Greeks everyone knows they were on top
of the world they've viewed themselves
very highly so why did they depict their
genitalia is so small right it seems
contradictory yeah that's that's exactly
what it is you can see right right yes
but actually it wasn't no okay well
thank you very much okay bring in a
whiteboard here and you know actually
I'm going to aim this at you a little
more because I want people to uh it
actually was fascinating when I found
out about it yeah you just realized not
all cultures they really aren't the same
no and not all are equal very deep yeah
so yeah as you can see here the Greeks
you know just by simple observation they
notice the more erudite and uh
intelligent one was right the smaller so
this actually goes up here so yeah okay
the smaller one's penis was so they
believe that a small penis was a sign of
being sort of part of the upper class
intellectual correct yep and so as you
got you know larger here you were more
you know barbarian-like that's what they
okay they don't want to be rude but you
know actually oh larger penises in
ancient Greek was more representative of
animalistic lust so it was more
representative of animals for example
the Seder and overlay here yeah okay
yeah I was gonna get to that okay yeah
he's okay yeah yeah all right okay cool
yeah all right so we have that so uh
that was just simple observation but
when we revisit history and we actually
combine that this is yeah this is the
Greek history this is Greek history just
our sources are available at a lot of
car.com and when we re-measure this now
using modern instruments and science we
find the same thing how to hire your
your IQ as you know in modern day the
the smaller your penises
what's that green graph at the bottom oh
this is just uh outlawed you know
there's like little dots that's just
points that weren't graphed okay like
data yeah those are just data points
yeah I don't know that I understand the
historical accuracy here it is true that
the Greeks believe that obviously it was
a sign of being erudite but I don't know
that it's scientific to say now that
smaller penises well this is I mean we
measured this is all using the
scientific method and I don't know this
is all real measurement I don't know
that yeah I don't know that you you did
I don't know that there's a correlation
between a smaller uh penis and a higher
IQ well I'm I mean are you involved in
the uh The Sciences or I'm not involved
I'm just I'm just I'm just wondering I'm
just saying yeah this is real
measurements Greek friends call me the
dumb Beast
[Laughter]
I'm not sure I mean we could have you in
the lab if you want to come by you know
we're always looking to add to the to
the studies yeah bringing him and Dennis
Rodman yeah we can get up yes everyone
in the studio wants to come by we can
all add yeah but I don't think so
because I think you're just gonna say
that everybody's dumb I don't know who
funded the research if this is yeah
the penis Institute funded the research
okay and let me let me ask you this
professor were you a part of this
research oh yeah of course I mean I'm a
scientist so okay so you subjected
yourself and what did you well I you
know a bit proud to admit that I have
statistically one of the most average
penises ever recorded okay all right
thank you Professor penis I don't think
this is a productive anymore Professor
penis everybody
[Music]
they really were about the motion of the
ocean weren't they yes I mean like
literally during battle and such yeah
can you imagine being the Greeks and
you're like guys we got a real problem
here uh let's make it sound good that
they're all small yeah how do we do that
we're real smart guys tell everybody
Joey's an animal yeah also we need to uh
come up with a reason for the long
weekends yeah all right at war ah I
can't I can't with you sweetheart I'll
lose all my powers
but what else were we supposed to do we
were on a ship for almost two weeks yeah
what am I gonna go on a Labor Day
weekend Siege and not have sex with Kyle
come on what what it's bonding time
it's the smartest guy I know
this is
Sparta nightclub oh hey hey where where
did the people who are fighting oh I
guess they didn't show up oh my gosh oh
whoa Good Lucky Draw well I guess we'll
do other stuff we've just got this
romantic fireplace and all this Mead I
mean we're here not a woman for Miles
look at all this wine who wants to get
loose
just a couple of hundred guys with some
Mead fireplace and small penises what or
what
the boat died we don't have Motors yet
oh that's even worse one guy's like I
brought Scrabble no you didn't no no it
didn't happen
all right guys just cutting the sails
but but what about the body oil it's
Body Oil necessary
middle night Pirates yeah
who knew that's it with old Persians
that's it with these Persians
oh okay hey speaking of uh gay
Victoria's Secret uh this is something
and we're gonna go to uh I guess I guess
we're running pretty well you know let's
have fun who cares we should still do it
okay still do it here on YouTube yeah
yeah okay all right then we'll do the
other segment all right because there's
no way we could do that on YouTube no
way no now okay first off let me get a
sip of water here so you guys can hold
the fort I'm very strong so we're gonna
talk about we're gonna watch this
something not sexy now okay
so the Victorious it's just as this is
going to be very upsetting to me yes
Victoria's Secret Angels um they're not
going to be a thing anymore and they
haven't done a damn thing to anybody
yeah they're just beautiful angels they
are just yes yeah
their feet hurt from falling from Heaven
they're not diabetes which is what
they're going to replace them with yeah
it's true had Victoria's Secret so
they're claiming they're no longer going
to have a stereotypical model look
they're going to be real like a lot
earlier yes
because these days it's all about
inclusion uh the New York Times
published an article
and this change in branding and they
interviewed new Victoria's Secret Angels
so uh the soccer player Megan Rapinoe uh
is the I didn't know who she was yeah
um yeah there we go we're going to the
soccer player going from the right to
the left
cool as well as Victoria's Secret chief
executive uh Martin Waters okay let me
read you a few highlights and let me
explain to you
why everything that this new exec thinks
is incorrect okay yeah a lot of a lot of
people out there like I just got
to be I mean it's only for myself no no
no no no no no
you're wrong everything that you think
about Victoria's Secret is wrong and
don't take this away from me
[Music]
so Martin Waters said we need to stop
being about what men want and to be
about what women want it's not how long
that's not how lingerie works for the
exact same reason that my wife green
lights my underwear she's the only one
who's going to see them yes they're not
comfortable lingerie is not for you
that's the thing like if if you were
left if it was just about comfort you
why would you be wearing a crocheted
thong
I think right be comfortable and cutting
the lawn do what I tell you woman
I need some entertainment we need to be
about what women want which I now I
could understand
no I couldn't but I think that I'll I'll
give him the benefit of the doubt I
would have initially if it was we want
things that are more comfortable for
women but also sexy because no that's
not it now you understand why they want
to go the route of over over oversized
lesbian because that's the key Mark I
think we're getting a little esoteric in
our marketing I don't know how Don
Draper would respond to this
they make sweatpants though that say
pink that's for the comfort days right
but what's wrong with a woman wanting to
feel pretty for a guy hold on Dave
where's the pink
well where's the word word pink is
across the butt okay all right so it
could have been down the leg but it's
they chose not to put it there they
chose to put it somewhere else and when
you read things do you technically look
at them well why did they put the pink
where the stink is it doesn't make any
sense come on it's true
but they're totally for the guys as well
come on yeah let's look let's be honest
being juicy makeup is also not always
now I understand that women enjoy these
things however of course specifically
how do we even go from makeup white the
Rouge on the cheeks right that's to
stimulate in lipstick stimulate the
flushing that happens during a sexual
encounter that is why it is sexually
attractive why are we attracted to
birthing hips large breasts these are
biological evolutionary mechanisms that
women have dressed to try and accentuate
in different ways throughout history
yeah the reason that heels exist because
they actually tone and shape and lift
the buttocks and men have none of that
we don't have any of those things most a
teenager we got a zit you're gonna see
it and I think I'm offensive by a man
it's like let's make their breasts look
a little more pouty and make it hard to
run yeah
then tell them they can teach them then
tell them they can be secret agents and
strong as a man
[Laughter]
fantasy oh there you go that'll be Jason
born in stilettos okay so then miss
rappino the lesbian soccer player who uh
speaks for the majority of American
women apparently yeah what could go
wrong with this move
it was Miss rappino said bluntly talking
about the previous Victoria's Secret
brand patriarchal sexist viewing not
just what it meant to be sexy but what
the clothes were trying to accomplish
through a male lens and through what men
desired and it was very much marketed
toward younger women and that message
was harmful uh you know what else is
marketed to young people
everything everything but gold depends
and reverse mortgages let's be clear all
video games all athletic wear all
sporting equipment this is why that's
the most valuable demographic because
young people tend to spend money on
stupid [ __ ] old people either are smart
enough to realize they don't need said
stupid [ __ ] they don't have room for
said stupid [ __ ] or they like the way
said stupid [ __ ] looks but they can't do
anything about it anyway that's why
everything is marketed to young people
what do they think is going to happen if
you put somebody in charge who
apparently lesbians don't care about
that the looks of the what it's gonna
end up being like JC Penney's like we
already have that granny panties are
already a thing JCP
you know me JCPenney's here because of
me
exactly like this lady same with the
trucks those are marketed maybe you know
to lesbians and young men who are going
to use those trucks to take the
mannequins from Victoria
oh they're gonna take last year's model
yes oh is that the is that the new plus
you can keep that oh oh is this thing
not gonna need it I don't need the first
iteration anything you work out the
Kinks so it's gonna be great yeah
they're one ladies carrying out an old
mannequin there's nine guys carrying in
the new one
like Gaston trying to break the Beast
Castle kill the Beast oh
do you want this in the window because
you're gonna need a much bigger window
yeah we're gonna have to bust out this
wall you're gonna need a window like an
Apple Store yeah do you guys have like a
piano mover thing yeah we need that yeah
yeah and I don't know what to anyway
okay these are the 30 Arbuckle jeans
Megan Rapinoe then this and but this
lady is the
yeah this lady is not because she's a
lesbian because no she doesn't
understand just you're ruining things
She's a Lesbian she should totally get
why we want to look at that no no no no
no no no no look if that made sense if
that made sense then they they're
attracted to the Wonder
the wondrous Beauty and all the Splendor
that is woman and then they pick a woman
who smashes beer cans on their head and
shops at Orvis right that's true
yeah you know what Victoria's Secret
drives an avalanche right yeah you know
what Victoria's Secret was missing all
this time and Eddie Bauer yeah yeah
these jeans have a lifetime warranty
they do it anymore that's not a joke no
no at least they used to impressive uh
as a gay woman
I think a lot about what we think is
sexy and we are afforded the ability to
do that because I don't have to wear the
traditional sexy thing to be sexy and I
don't think the tradition the
traditional thing is sexy when it comes
to my partner or people I've dated I
think functionality is probably the best
thing we could possibly achieve in life
yeah sorry possibly the sexiest thing we
could achieve in life if that were true
you're best bet at getting laid would be
old sweatpants and a hockey helmet
take your take your girlfriend or wife
out to a nice dinner in a Looney Tunes
t-shirt
or one of those whoa
whoa that she got next to the Pasty shop
right
and a radar detector yeah trust me it
goes both ways there's a way to present
yourself at certain times and there's
nothing wrong with it no absolutely
nothing and look here's the here's the
beauty if you don't want to wear
Victoria's Secret or lingerie
there's everything else yes
you are oh you're looking for not sexy
things there's plenty of those we've
seen you wear them before have you heard
of Dillard's the name is sort of
self-explanatory but it's very unsexy we
believe you'll be pleased yes you just
walked past Spencer's Gifts to get here
I can tell because you have one of those
plasma balls in your bag since you
turned it off I knew I knew you were
either a fortune teller or an [ __ ]
well look by the way you made a great
point we talked about this before the
show we don't want the porn that is the
Angels right now no there's a middle
ground yeah there's a middle ground here
like we don't want like 15 year old kids
that's all you need that's porn to them
right they don't need anything else yeah
keep it inside the shop you show the
stuff that's kind of sexy outside like
you know keep in other words it
shouldn't go anything say Canada it
shouldn't go any further oh no you don't
know what Montreal no not Canada our
biggest sign is we don't need to be
candidate at this point though porn is
porn to them it's true it's so available
I don't think that there's anything
wrong with there's really nothing wrong
with with any male or female sexuality
there is no there isn't but I understand
what he's no no I get what he's saying
or a 14 year old's face I I get that
yeah you know Arnold was uh stopped at
the border when he came with a muscle
magazine yeah yeah because they thought
it was porn they thought it was porn I'm
just saying keep it to like swimsuit
marketing of course absolutely I mean
like we all know that the Sears wishlist
wishlist catalog when we were kids that
that was
they had the whole lingerie section yeah
they did that was enough well it was
then it was real your mom would be like
what do you pick out the items that you
want like it was a Scholastic Book Fair
and should be going through this year's
wish catalog but she she'd turn it over
and it was like uh it was like a like a
like a a limestone tablet four pages or
just oh yeah well it was like the
swimsuit before they decided to put
dudes in it yeah
so she
Paloma elliser saw part of her role as
lobbying for Victoria's Secret to
increase this is this is a quote to
increasing its sizing to x x x x x x x x
x x x x XL so Victoria's Secret selling
tarps what is that yeah you know what
really you know what would really good
let's do away with the pink let's do it
away how about a nice Lacy Free Willy
hammock let's make that I think the tag
should say Barnum and Bailey
[Laughter]
oh my gosh
no it's not that size at all not at all
points yeah yeah she just wants the look
people want to feel sexy at all kinds of
sizes you guys miss my joke of the
killing a cheetah the other day from
road yeah good for you that sometimes
sometimes big ladies you know okay look
I told you you were doing well don't go
and explain a joke from three days ago
yeah that's true I'll kill haul you yeah
you're already doing great yeah which by
the way
xxxl one more X you're dead ah yeah I
mean I think you're dead over the eyes
yeah one more X only comes in coffin
sizes but this is also and look we're
gonna go to uh to mug Club here in a
second uh you guys if you're watching on
Rumble thing you can smash the rumble
button you can let them on a smash
Rumble button uh and smash of course the
like button if you're on YouTube leave a
comment what you think about Victoria's
Secret it's destroying everything I love
sucking my will to live oh no I'm
kidding there are still other places
um but here here's the deal This Is A
Lie To young women now I don't think
that young women 15 year olds have any
business going and buying Lacy thongs I
think this is something we've talked
about there's there's an age-appropriate
Factor okay and just like we've talked
about I don't think that you should be
thrusting women in thongs in front of
every uh every child every 12 to 15 year
old child but I also don't think that
you should have uh you should have pubic
lines at uh Hollister and I don't
understand why when you're in the guy
section it's naked guys on the posters
and the women in the women's section
switch
but the point is this is a lot of young
women saying you don't need a man to be
happy and if you find a man you don't
need to make him happy you shouldn't
we've now have gone further with you
shouldn't want to make him happy do you
know who basically basically dresses me
my wife because I don't give a rat's ass
why now here's the thing obviously if I
pick something that I want to wear I
have I have control of my own body we
all do right but any man here who has a
wife
would you continually wear something
that your wife hated she's like I just
think that you look I think you look
like crap I like to go to Abercrombie
and see the DJ play underneath a
gigantic poster of two men playing
shirtless football yeah but I kid you
not I went to Hollister because my wife
was like try this on I tried on
something the way she looked at me I
bought three okay I will never ever shop
there again she was looking at the
poster over your shoulder but now you
have to wear shitty shirts yeah it
looked like it was you it's just right
right past me I was like I misread that
yeah can I get out of the Hollister Club
no but seriously no one would none of us
would wear anything because we want to
please our wife for the same reason that
when you are in a loving relationship
you find a middle ground when it comes
to dinner and you look with a man guess
what Dr Laura was right about this I'm
always amazed when people would get mad
at her she was canceled because she
repeated someone else saying the n-word
right a number of years ago
um
feeding means a lot to a husband it's
not that it's expected of you as what we
demand but guess what it's a way that we
receive love men they receive sex
actually as a sign that you find them
attractive that you find them it means a
lot to a guy when they're married this
is this is something that a lot of women
need to understand tenderness warmth and
what have we said no you don't need
those things what we're expected to be
docile no no no it's just an attractive
quality in a woman to a man for the same
reason that lingerie panties are and for
the same reason that you like tall guys
or people who you believe can provide
for you these things are attractive when
you tell young women actually you should
recreate everything you are in the image
of a soccer playing lesbian and then
they wonder why no one but soccer
playing lesbians are interested in them
and then their window has closed and
their eggs don't work guess what happens
they become miserable and they are in an
exclusive demographic at a higher risk
of psychological disorder she realizes
the the number of women over 35 who
identify as having some kind of an
actual cycle mental illness it is
skyrocketed yeah and it's got and it's
just a lie to women and it's a lie that
many young women don't figure out until
it's too late I'm not saying and I'm
very clear I'm not saying that women
should find pride in just how they look
that's not the problem with fat Pride
but I am saying that if you lie to women
and say you're not wearing lawn you're
doing it for yourself
well that's not true then you just wear
sweatpants and a Jaffa helmet like it
really is not true it's a lie and it's
going to make people miserable yeah
absolutely and you basically just told
them to be completely self-centered
right just do whatever you like is
totally fine it doesn't matter if your
husband likes it or not or the guy that
you're trying to date likes how you
dress or not it Just matters if you like
it now there's a middle ground right you
don't need to be a hoe right and go out
wearing terrible things but you also
can't go out dressed like a hoodlum and
well think about it we're going to find
you attractive if as a woman you're
wearing nasty clothing not that you know
we've told young women now go out in
public like lizzo go out in public like
cardi B and dress to use your word like
a hoe go out and show it all off but in
the confines of your own home make sure
that none of that is being done to
please your husband great message let's
see how that works out I think our
Tourette's statue might have to get
going so we'll let him go for the
monkeys I mean YouTube thank you uh kind
of next week cultural appropriation
month so guess what Thursday it's
California
is no longer part of the United States
I've just declared YouTube piss off